so it is my very great pleasure to
introduce Stefan Chandan today as our
first company of scholars lecturer for
this academic year as you probably know
this series that we call the dean's
lecture company of scholars is a great
opportunity for us to hear from some of
our most distinguished scholars and
innovators on campus and also the chance
to find out about things going on on our
campus outside of our own discipline I'm
especially glad to have stuff on here
today as he is instrumental in bringing
a unique program to Yale that is having
a huge impact on the preservation of
cultural heritage which i think is
arguably one of the most important human
Devers that we undertake both for the
importance of understanding art history
to figure out how to navigate the
present and we have ample examples of
the importance of this in our amazing
museums and tourism and museums and huge
efforts to resurrect artifacts of past
civilizations preserving that culture
cultural preservation is especially
important these days with very acute
threats caused by conte armed conflict
around the world and climate change
causing causing huge climate associated
disasters Stefan enters this scene of
cultural preservation with a broad
experience in science including material
deterioration Diagnostics micro
analytics Condit ology and
non-destructive mechanical testing he's
at the forefront of efforts to bring
cutting-edge scientific diagnostic tools
to understand how we can best preserve
artifacts his Institute for the
preservation of cultural heritage on the
west campus welcome scientists and
students from across the Yale campus
as well as from other universities and
other countries much of his recent
effort has been responding to natural
disasters in ways that safe cultural
artifacts in the in museums and
elsewhere if you get the chance to visit
the Center for preservation of cultural
heritage on West Campus I encourage you
to go it's a truly amazing nearly one of
a kind place prior to arriving at Yale
in 2014 Stefan was the director of the
russian research laboratory at the
national museums in berlin the oldest
museum laboratory in the world we are
indeed very fortunate that he's now part
of our community and Yale and I welcome
you here to hear about his work thank
you then very much and the purchase for
the delay actually quite interestingly
it's true that I changed from the
world's oldest conservation institution
to the world's youngest conservation
institution I think that you know Aslan
was already saying cultural and natural
heritage is increasingly threatened with
destruction and not only by physical and
chemical causes but also by our changing
social and economic conditions and
natural and man-made disaster both are a
very important factor as as we could
recently learn over the past years
illustrated in a horrifying way by all
these war crimes as irina bokova
director general fiasco is calling that
war crimes in the middle east and africa
and i think it is quite clear that the
world is changing at a rapid pace and
research as well as academic education
must try to to keep up with this
development and I think this is the
challenge for us this is the challenge
for Yale to move the field of cultural
heritage preservation ahead in a
changing world and in a changing
environment so I would like to talk a
little bit about three main topics what
is cultural heritage I think it's
important to think a little bit about
what that mean
means what that can mean and to give
some examples a little bit about
preservation vs hazard risk and loss and
I try to combine two examples I mean you
could choose broadly from cultural
heritage computing to technical art
history from you know canvas to panel
painting you could do really a lot of
variety but I chose what I think I at
the moment the hottest topics in our
field the sustainable conservation in
green museum debate the plus/minus
dilemma about what is really affordable
in collections and and what is really
sustainability in conservation both in
museums and insights and of course also
that what is already mentioned the risks
to cultural heritage by disaster
man-made or natural and and try to
finish then with you know view who is
actually responsible for cultural
heritage preservation and how how can we
be successful if you if you think about
cultural heritage most people think this
is all about paintings people think in
our Institute you know people come in
with the van Gogh painting and every
morning and and leave in the evening I
don't know with another painting and
it's true it is about paintings there's
a lot of paintings in the conservation
laboratory out on west campus paintings
are an important part of cultural
heritage but they're kind of a western
part of cultural heritage they're kind
of this white Western cultural heritage
they are continents which made centuries
without paintings continents paintings
have challenges like this one it's the
very famous painting from the national
zoo in germany the up time I felt by
Caspar David Friedrich they have
varnishes which yellow and which change
the appearance and and there's a lot of
work to do on paintings but but if you
look at the world's cultural heritage we
have to take into consideration much
much broader scope I want to give some
examples thingvellir world heritage site
in Iceland one of the oldest
parliament's 930 until I think delayed
18th century a traditional legislative
union for Iceland to actually eight nine
hundred years of democracy but also
plays of what is called the Eurasian
North American plate boundaries rift
which runs through Iceland and they
break apart and move actually action
people say that's where the European and
the American plates are like coming
together the opposite is actually true
because they're moving apart moving
apart with approximately two centimeters
per year but this is a world heritage
site and this is characterized by its
outstanding universal value well let's
go to a time about 7,000 BC 5,000 busy
long time ago one of the most early
anthropomorphic statues from an Castle
it's a it's a site near Amman in Jordan
nobody really knows what they were made
for there I mean unfortunately is not as
nice as on my computer you can hardly
see them look a little bit like a
mixture of ET and unfortunately I'm
sorry that the picture should be a
little bit brighter
we go a few thousand years to the Future
to the Year 1300 BC we have another
famous historic figure Queen Nefertiti
spouse of far away H not on let's make
another chump a thousand years to the
future we come to the royal tombs in
Petra also jordan also world heritage
site since 1985 a site which suffers a
lot of threats you know from from
earthquake colors of structures erosion
due to flooding rain water salt
weathering lots and lots of threats
around the sides and actually whole
landscapes because those are not
buildings those are rock carved for say
its tomb façades tomb actually ancient
tombs if we if you think about tombs the
project we were working on just a few
weeks ago with our institute is a
project on jewish cemetery in germany
from the 1900s and last 19th century so
also that as a site as a site which
carries information as a site which
carries values which we would attribute
as cultural heritage another famous
object again from my home country in
germany the three magic shrine the
proust important catholic reliquary
actually largest catholic reliquary the
three kings or the three wise man shrine
in cologne cathedral which has like 5
million visitors per year gold enamel
well but cultural heritage is also this
I don't know if you recognize that
that's the USS Pueblo in the port in
Pyongyang in North Korea I worked in
North Korea some years ago and of course
I was taking to that museum site with
the very famous incident on january 23rd
1968 when north korea captured that navy
ship together with 80 sailors but it can
be also small you can hear see dwarf
happy from disney animation cells also
how cultural heritage in the same
stand as audio tapes which you may have
at home which may slowly look like this
and not be playable anymore cultural
heritage in in in a wider sense also
comprises object like this one this is
one of the first translations in to the
vamp analogue language or from from 1663
of the Bible it's in the pequot museum
not far from here illustrating the
importance of languages of endangered
languages of vanishing languages which
are as close to cultural heritage as the
paintings which I was showing in the
beginning of my presentation I want to
show you now an object and I will get
back to this object later in the lecture
and I would like many has anybody seen
that before already know do we have an
idea what that could be and it looks
like a brick with a little bit of mortar
the information i'm going to give at
this stage is that if we look at
cultural heritage at home an average
American will approximately own more
than 400 electronic appliances during
his or her lifetime that could be one of
them doesn't really look like it I admit
looks like a break with a little bit of
lime wash or lime water but I will soon
show you that it has completely
different meaning in terms of cultural
heritage and of course cultural heritage
coming to the end now what it can be it
is attracting people people want to see
it and unfortunately it's also too dark
this is the Trevi Fountain I was there a
few weeks ago in Rome it's just after
restoration finished in in October and
you see the typical picture actually
don't see which is suggesting black mass
but this hundreds and hundreds of people
in front of the Trevi Fountain and
everybody's jealous that I can make the
photo from the Palazzo probably from the
other side to them and not the usual way
so one thing is clear if you look at
cultural heritage it can be old it can
be new like in this same
by Madison annunci all art has been
contemporary at some point all these
artifacts all these objects have been a
product of their time so let's after
this introduction let's go into the
questions of preservation versus hazard
and let's look a little bit about
sustainable conservation and the green
museum I think Yale University is a
place where I don't need to waste my
time on explaining what actually
sustainability means I don't need to
speak about hands Calvin calibrates or
the brundtland commission just maybe one
sentence a green resume is about to
incorporate the three columns of
sustainability into its operation
programming and facilities the three
columns are actually the economic column
the ecologic column and the social
column and the social calendar is kind
of the conservation part in this game we
also recognize that we have in our in
our debate about the green museum in our
lecture in our museum environment we
notice a change in objectives in the
last ten years twenty years and actually
the United States have been at the
forefront of this development we see
that we go away from rule-based
preservation from rule-based protection
and we're changing slowly into something
which we caught call management of
change we know that things change we
know that our objects change i mean is
enough to take a look in the mirror
every morning and you realize things on
this planet change and we have to go to
a pragmatic risk assessment and you
can't just say it has to be like this it
has to be fifty percent flat because we
have to pay for this relative humidity
we have to pay for the hvac systems and
I think Yale is a place where this
debate is at home since since a long
time so a short excursion on what is
called the good museum climate or the
plus/minus dilemma traditionally
climatisation takes place through
natural air exchange through leakage I
mean no building is really sealed you
know you have joins windows doors the
first HVAC
systems in museums come from the 1950s
1960s in Europe maybe late 60s in the US
was a little bit earlier so imagine
everything which is a little bit older
than 1960 has lived its life in an
environment without climatisation okay
it's very important to note general
conservation requests are we want to
have low temperature we want to have
relative humidity according to sorption
characteristics both temperature and
humidity should be constant as as much
as possible we don't really want to have
high air speed because that leads to
dust deposition and also we don't have
too much dust in the air a compartment
because it will deficit and then soil
and be at some point also difficult to
remove well so far so easy but why do we
have a museum requirement of like 20
degrees Celsius and fifty percent our
age where does it come from objects art
objects most art objects they don't need
20 degrees Celsius they actually much
better with 15 or 14 but the human
comfort zone the zone for the the guards
the people working in the museum well
they they don't really want to work
below 19 degrees Celsius but it's kind
of hypocrite to say well we need to have
a museum climate of 20 degrees because
if we have a priority for conserving
artifacts we don't need this high
temperature so one development which
took place over the past years is is
steered by by a group called the bees or
group the bees or group is a group of
the big museum lenders like the
Metropolitan Museum the British Museum
the Louvre they came up with this idea
to relax our climate standards and I am
actually it's interesting to note that
at Yale also the art gallery has you
know very seriously considered to apply
to this interim guidelines of the bezel
group which which required which they
actually for many classes of objects you
know we can work with forty to sixty
percent our age and we should have a
limited fluctuation also
think very important is the last
sentence is quite often overlooked a
conservative evaluation is essential in
establishing appropriate environmental
conditions or of course the conservator
has to look is it really is that this
object really belonged to that class
which can I mean keep up very well from
40 to 60 and it is a hot hot debate I
organized the conference in 2013 in
Berlin there was another one in 2012
actually we're lagging behind you as you
know it yes this discussion is much
older it started in 1990s in the UK the
dialogues for the new century the asu
conference i think was in 2010 but the
plus/minus dilemma or 2011 maybe in any
case earlier than us over there in
europe it's a hot topic and there's like
this one group which says stable is safe
let's not relax the standards and the
other group which says we can probably
relax the standard without compromising
the preservation of our of our heritage
and and there's a group which tries to
look at this in a very pragmatic and
realistic way and they say the reality
is not 50 flat this is the reality for
engineers you know in the dream world of
Engineers everything is 50 flat in the
reality for example a church in Venice
you have a relative humidity fluctuation
between thirty and eighty percent over a
year's period you know in the red if the
temperature blew the there are H it's
going up and down and it's going up and
down in many museums I show you data
from the national gallery in Berlin you
know in the the magenta form is the is
the relative humidity so 60 I think 220
in the winter actually with pictures
like this one this is a very famous
building by miss van der Rohe a glass
steel well if you want to have fifty
percent rh in a winter night when you
have minus 15 degrees outside you will
have condensation on the windows you
will have ice on the windows you first
generate some kind of an indoor fountain
and then a lot of corrosion along the
steel bars and that is not a 50-percent
flat building and that leads actually to
this try and you know those Peaks to
have
a dryer relative humidity well but if we
look at our situation here at Yale let's
go to the Great Hall the Sistine Chapel
of paleontology in the Peabody Museum
here you have the region which would be
recommended like you know in in sorry in
temperature sorry is this this should be
not no I'm sure it's not 30 40 why is it
in blue but in any case it's 22 eighty
percent our age is the fluctuation is
there is the real situation in this hall
or if we look at the environmental
science centers the solo gee collection
you see that also there we're not as
much fluctuating but we go from 2265 up
and down and up and down so we don't
really have the 50 flat I could show you
now diagrams you know from the British
Museum from the Louvre from the China
National Museum of China nmc from many
museums but I don't have the time and I
don't think it's worth it the reality is
that museums collections have this
problem that they have visitors the
visitors actually I'm a would be so much
easier for us if there were no visitors
because because if you have to open the
door in the morning and close it in the
evening you have an exchange with the
outside environment and the visitors
come and they disturb that equilibrium
so well from building physics point of
view of course that is not the whole
picture but they are at least a
challenge so I think as I said before we
have an acceptance of a less strict
climate control growing the I come see
see declaration 2014 in in in the fall
in September 2014 says that care of
collections should be achieved in a way
that does not assume air conditioning
passive methods simple technology that
is easy to maintain air circulation
lower energy solutions should be
considered we also know this is I think
nine 2007 almost ten years ago a master
thesis at the Smithsonian that
energy consumption ver as a function of
a variety and temperature and relative
energy as a function of the allowed
fluctuation goes down in an extra
banished way which means in the other
way the more narrow you want to have
your corridor for your storage and for
your museum the more money you pay and
it goes up exponentially as you can see
here you know these figures are all on
the web the Office of Sustainability and
other sources that you provide that you
see that energy use ad Yale sees you
know the museum buildings at the top the
art gallery for example the collection
Study Center in the Beinecke library I
mean there's some like environmental
science center and the tack which are
still higher related to two cubic feet
but the museum's are high and and we
have to take we have to face reality we
can look where are we comparing to other
institutions so if that's us the article
i read the science center that is a
typical museum in denmark built maybe 10
years ago that is the new passive store
in valley in denmark you can hardly see
that it is possible to build storage and
museum conditions with 20 30 50 times
less energy consumption than we do it
might be worth to take a look at this
museum store in valet first of all very
low exchange rate just a little bit of
natural infiltration no insulation on
the floor lower temperatures
temperatures between 7 and 16 degrees
increase the objects lifetime for a
factor of about 2.5 comparing to twenty
percent are a temperature and fifty
percent are aged so the conclusions of
this little excursion on the green
museum debate strict climate control in
most cases brings little benefit but
high considerably high costs most
observation experience in conservation
and research show that variations of
plus minus ten fifteen percent
safe we know how to build energy
efficient buildings and if preservation
is a priority and not human comfort we
also know how to build almost zero
energy storage buildings in theory so I
told you before that the problem in the
museum are the visitors that was of
course a joke because you know if you go
to the van Gogh Museum in Amsterdam it
says go as often as possible to the
museum and that would be also my
recommendation to you go as often as you
can to the museum's just I mean close
the door quickly when you enter and
don't let it open we think that we
should work on on you know linking the
cultural heritage preservation to the 17
United Nations sustainable development
goals to have them to have cultural
heritage included in the development of
climate risk indicators I mean we have
just the big meeting in Paris this week
going on a global climate change
cultural heritage experts are lacking at
the table I think this is we still have
a way to go and some you know lectures
to give to convince that cultural
heritage and this and this costs of
energy are not peanuts I I can give you
an example from the nationalism in
Germany in one case of the of the museum
not a museum island but the museum forum
we talk about 3.6 million euro per
winter / / seat / winter season 3.6
million euro savings through relaxation
of climatic standards it's a lot of
money involved here I come to risk to
cultural heritage by man-made and
natural disasters now it's like the
harder part actually of this lecture
fire is the worst I mean among all
agents of decoration fire takes things
in a in a short time in a part of a
second I mean everybody working in
conservation can be happy if it was not
involved in the fire event but it may
happen and you may be lucky you may not
be lucky fires have a long impact on
tradition I just
show you here one example of the rocio
the square in Lisbon you can see here
very typical Portuguese firewalls inside
the buildings which were introduced in
the architecture after the devastating
earthquake and tsunami and fire
everything came on one day of November
first 1755 now that's a long time ago we
have disasters I mean in the last year's
everywhere and I just show you a few
examples they had soaked in Amalia
library in Vemma burned down in 2004
lost lots of manuscripts a whole library
actually and you couldn't even say
something went wrong the fire brigade
was there after a few minutes but books
burn I mean good fifty thousand books
were burned and and many of them not to
be recovered to costs of recovery
estimated like 50 60 million that's why
you know our colleagues in Nara have
everywhere a packet of water you know
just to be there in the moment when it
starts after fire flood is well
life-shaping experience the flood of
august 2002 which affected Germany the
Czech Czech Republic at that time I was
working for the Gary but I was on a on a
mission to Europe and I I went there and
I saw the museum depositor in terrasen I
saw the National architectural archive
where you had everything from the
medieval cathedral to the Bauhaus to
Mendelssohn 3 meter underwater I was in
Dresden these are photos from Dresden
when museum curators that's actually the
director of the gallery atomizer and the
chief conservator market malice keeper
when they try to I understand like to
their knees in the water and they try to
move five thousand objects just to
higher floors because the funny thing of
course the huge elevator was the first
thing which didn't work anymore when the
water came and the state
case was too small so you can see what
they did with his French painting they
were just hanging it up trying to hang
it up as high as possible hoping the
water will not fill two stories well
yeah this very experiences which which
you know you could never forget if you
work in cultural heritage preservation
because this is one of the most
important collection of Europe and if
you have five thousand objects which are
underwater almost and you have to call
in the people from the street to carry
take this Raphael painting just you know
carry it up two floors give it to the
conservator yeah you you never forget
that you see a very exhausted
director-general my friend Martin Road
sitting here you know because they just
brought everything up 2009 the municipal
archive of the city of Cologne 30
kilometres of archival material just
collapsed in a hole of a subway
construction estimates are that we will
need 30 to 50 years to recover that and
a billion of euro a lot of the material
has been rescued but it looks like this
the whole history of the city of Cologne
26 of december 2003 the RG bomb Citadel
in in iran an earthquake 6.5 on the
Richter scale not really much but a
complete destruction of the Citadel and
the surrounding city 30,000 people
killed earthquakes are a disaster for
cultural heritage of course a human
disaster yeah we could see that this
year in April 25 in Nepal 7.8 magnitude
earthquake horrible damage to the world
heritage site of the Kathmandu Valley
but also to many many other areas in
Nepal not necessarily in the in the very
well accessible Kathmandu Valley part
but you know and the mountainsides that
is the natural side but we also have the
man-made disasters and you know those
all of you will
have heard about I mean what is
happening in the past years and I keep
saying that is in my career I work since
86 in the field of preserving cultural
heritage it's definitely the worst year
it's every year is worse than the one
before and it's definitely the worst
year of my career in terms of
destruction and loss just a few views
Yemen Arabiya Felix the happy Arabia
since this spring you see the famous
side of shabam hot remote I mean there's
a war there are air strikes there is no
world heritage city of Santa are bombed
by the saudi-led coalition multi-story
adobe buildings unique I mean those of
you who were in Yemen it's it's a very
very unique place it's a very
outstanding unique cultural heritage and
it's not really very much discussed
about but it's a it's a tragedy and it
also refers to the Iron Age size for
example I heard from a friend a few
weeks ago that the temple to al Makka
which is the 7th century BC Temple has
been destroyed in the war bye-bye I mean
or at least heavily damaged by by bombs
we hear a lot about Syria and we're
going to hear here as well but Yemen
shouldn't be forgotten and let's go back
a little bit into the history let's go
back to this city some of you may
recognize it's a beautiful city former
Yugoslavia the city of sarajevo sarajevo
was kind of the turning point when
cultural heritage really became a
primary target in military conflicts not
a secondary damage but really a primary
target very very painful for all of us
in Europe at that point on 25 of August
1992 the shelling of the National
Library of Bosnia and Herzegovina which
caused the loss of 700 manuscripts I
mean a library which had before they
attack 1.5 million volumes and over
150,000 rare books imagined that to
happen here to the Beinecke library for
example it's not imaginable it's it's
it's a disaster for the country its
disaster for the
continent we all know about the old
bridge of Master of course famous bridge
16th century bridge standing well for
more than 400 27 years but then
destroyed on november nine nineteen
ninety-three by Croat forces in the war
and reconstructed after 2001 and
inaugurated 2004 it's like the the
poster child of the Bosnian conflict is
this bridge but we shouldn't forget we
have dozens and dozens of churches of
masks of monsters whenever you drive
through bosna you see places like this
one or like this one you know that there
was a mosque there was a church and
there's not much reconstructed you go to
the year 2001 Afghanistan in Bamiyan the
destruction of the Bamiyan Buddhas also
world heritage also disaster by the
Taliban this is more or less all what is
left these are little pieces you know
collected by the drama nokomis mission
and you know painted pieces sorry but it
is not much left look at Molly with the
al Qaeda invasion in 2012 the mausoleum
of alpha Moya one of the most famous
shrines in dis destroyed by the
Islamists in Timbuktu this is from the
same side the famous University
manuscripts Timbuktu University was kind
of the Yale of the 12th century of
Africa it is a very famous place four
hundred thousand manuscripts were there
4,200 were burned like this one but
still hundreds of thousands were saved
they were saved because people took them
were hiding them in their garden we're
driving down to Bamako and and and that
is by the way probably one of the few
messages of my presentation that is what
sustainability means the people the
people the local people the stakeholders
if they are not with this effort if they
are not becoming the true monuments men
and heroes we are lost because no
university no monuments man of United
Nation no UNESCO is going to save that
that is a very good example the Malian
example to save hundreds of
thousands of the manuscripts by
engagement of local people well you may
have heard the Boko Haram Nigeria world
heritage site of succour hardly anybody
knows about the destruction but the big
loss last year this spring 18 of March
2015 you know the traces of fighting
after the attack and the Bardo Museum in
Tunisia you have these photos now from
everywhere in the world I didn't yet
come to Iraq I didn't just come to Syria
these feet photos you can see at the
Whitney Humanities Center in the
exhibition in doraville opus is the site
of dura-europos unfortunately the
projector is very weak but it's a site
in spring 2012 sorry in April 2012 year
and this is the side in 2014 and you can
see that each of this black holes is
kind as we were hearing is recently on a
panel on cultural heritage in terrorism
like a three meter deep hole which
looted that site as with my colleague
said from Acer into oblivion and and
that happens now day after day since
2012 in in the country of Syria it
happens in Africa this is from water
from Mali from janu janu janu do you
have this object turning out on the
market this photo is from the 2004 I
think from oma in southern Iraq is a
German excavation only this area is
excavated all that all this with cheese
around eyes what called illicit digging
taking objects out of that they're
bringing them to Turkey to Lebanon to
Thailand they're selling them you know
in China and Russia in the United States
everywhere they turn them into money we
have to speak about you know war crime
we have to speak about blood antiquities
and I'm very very happy to see that you
know there are efforts in the United
States by the United Nations by the
German government and others to really
stop to really fight that I mean modern
plague of illicit traffic it is a
nightmare it's affecting also here it's
a photo I took in chan chan in peru in
2005 and this by the way is how it looks
when you take a mural painting out of a
wall that's from the Silk Road in China
where German actually explorers took in
the early 20th century just cutting out
the pieces nice faces took them to
Berlin 700 square meter of their
paintings now in the National Museum but
that scarred rest is left and I found a
nice quote back from from the United
States from 1914 Henry fairford asprin
director of the American Museum of
Natural History said about China he said
such plunder and destruction are not
only despoiling China from some of the
garments of the ancient civilization but
actually tend to break down Chinese
society by depriving the Chinese people
of the Heritage besides scribbling
research and education in retarding
progress and that was true in 1914 and
that is true in 2015 and that is a place
where we have to work you know with here
at Yale with our university but also in
an international network to fight
against illicit traffic we have several
lectures in our lecture series over the
past months from colleagues from Glasgow
from London from from Oxford who spoke
about this topic and yeah i think we
cannot neglect it well terrorist attacks
go up you know it's clear we just have
to read the newspaper everywhere I
deliberately chose not to show any
photos of destruction because you've
seen these photos I could really hardly
stand them anymore because I have seen
them so often but I have to show you the
worst video from April 11 2015 the
destruction of asanas nacelles palace in
a Nimrod which was I think at that point
by ice is the worst video the deliberate
destruction of that palace but this is
not about Isis if I may say so this is
about the whole system there is the
Syrian regime the Islamic state the
Kurdish territory is the so-called Free
Syrian Army if you look percentage of
heavy loading in Syria I mean of course
Isis is here with 42 that's a very
recent publication by Acer from
september-october this year that is not
just about Isis Isis brings it to our
attention but there's many many people
involved in that I spoke about the
United Nations Security Council
resolution 2199
and also a bill which is in I think in
the Senate at this point if 93 in the
United States I mean kind of attempt to
ban trade of unproven install a fax from
from regions of conflict we have a new
German legislation also going on the
German government was just saying you
know yesterday it has to go through the
Parliament I do hope it will go through
i do hope it will become a game-changer
in this debate against illicit traffic
because i think it has to it has to
become we had conference in london on
cultural crisis in april together with
the Victoria and Albert Museum we had
panel discussions we had a long on
declaration actually eventually endorsed
by UNESCO intergovernmental organization
we just received actually another letter
by UNESCO director-general it in a book
over a few weeks ago and thanking yay
for for its engagement against you know
the war crimes in the middle east
against looting and for cultural
heritage preservation there's a lot of
conclusions in this declaration but I
have no time now to go into this I want
to finish now with the few words that
cultural heritage as I said before is in
our hands is in your hands is not just
something which happens somewhere it
happens right in front our doors I want
to mention hi Adele Assad famous
archaeologist 93 years old I mean in may
still we had conversations about palmyra
as you say or panera was about to fall
killed in a very cruel way in august in
in in palmyra by Isis this is the
colonnaded Street and I and I put that
quote it's I apologize for the very bad
english translation it's a quote by you
and working good it says somehow you
know some of the world's magnificant
things disappeared in war and coral who
protects and preserves one the biggest
lot yeah that is not the profession
translation ok that is German sounds
really poetic but that is about Kyle
sad I want to come back to this devices
here I guess that you don't know what
they are but they have to do with
cultural heritage preservation as much
as anything else i was showing in this
hour it is called the check radio the
czechoslovak radio and it wasn't the
documentary which is a contemporary art
exhibition germany few years ago 2013 so
when Czechoslovakia was invaded by the
Soviet Army in 1968 people resist it I
mean I can say that because I studied in
the socialist countries I'm kind of this
extinct soon extinct species you know
who spent some years growing up in the
socialist environment nowadays you have
to go to North Korea right that's the
only place where you can really enjoy
that feeling so I i say this with a
certain passion right so when when Jack
Slovakia was invaded people resisted to
the depression of political reforms who
quite creative means you may have heard
of the the soldier schwag also hashtag
that's very typical check after people
were forbidden to listen to radio
broadcasts like Radio Free Europe from
the United States they started attaching
antennas to bricks as a sign of protest
nothing more than painted bricks these
fake radio started to spread among the
population pretending to listen to them
and although they were useless as a
communication device they were
continuously confiscated by the Russian
army it is unclear if this was caused by
the genuine thought these were hidden
radio audio equipments or because they
were seen as an anarchic piece of art
that is the check radio and that is the
relation to cultural heritage from
people who really take a stake in it and
the other example which I want to show
is this one and you may say what kind of
a horrible painting is this river you
know they would never make it to the art
gallery here what is that well that is a
masterpiece by a teacher in Afghanistan
in Kabul his name is Mohammed use of us
a fee when the Taliban came and took
power he over-painted 120 paintings from
the National Museum in Kabul
with a water soluble paint with motifs
of rivers of forests because it was sure
that will the Taliban find these
paintings with depictions of animals of
human beings they will all destroy that
he is a very famous person I mean nobody
knows him but in my world he's a very
famous person I think people like a
little Assad like Mohammed use of a CV
how the people in the Czech Republic who
carried around bricks with the painted
antenna those are really the heroes of
our time in preserving of cultural
heritage we have to make sure we have to
realize historic places are the places
which give us our roots you know they
enhance the community the community
pride they teach to inspire us they make
in essence our community is more
attractive encourage you know travel
tourism they are assets for downtown
revitalization economic development I
didn't talk about it at all about the
power of economics and preservation how
much money is actually generated through
preservation of cultural heritage and
why why we pay 10 euro for a cappuccino
in st. Mark's Square in Venice and only
two euro in master a few miles away that
is the cultural heritage which makes the
difference I i think the ensuring also
the sustainability of preservation you
know taking the local stakeholders with
us and one of the most important
conclusions of the London declaration be
be generous you know be generous
creative and innovative in our support
to the colleagues on the ground in Syria
in Iraq in mohali Nigeria Tanzania
wherever in Yemen support United United
for heritage campaign a social media
campaign launched here in the Baghdad
museum or in University of Baghdad in
march this year and also take into
account the future because you know
cultural heritage is really as much
about the future as it is about to pass
so I thank you very much for your
attention for this journey through you
know this Cove of work of my minnow
research and also of the Institute's
research and I think my colleagues here
many colleagues have helped me with
photos from from Yale and from from
outside yell
thank you very much for your attention
so would answer any questions you have
and i'll just remind you we also have a
reception following in question yes
thank you Stefan perception illuminating
talks was really great I want to ask you
a question about possible conundrum of
sustainable preservation for of
sustainability and preservation and you
kind of alluded to this when you said
preservation Resource director were no
visitors so there are probably many
examples of this but I have one in mind
from the field from the kind of region
that I work in and that's the potala
palace or the famous house with the
Dalai Lama's at the time it was built in
the 17th century was the biggest
building in the world it was designated
as a UNESCO World Heritage Site and
after that that access to traditional
pilgrims as a site of kind of religious
practice and worship was strictly
limited at the same time because it was
on a world heritage site lists tourism
kind of went up and so the dynamics of
how the site is actually used in situ by
the stakeholders we refer to totally
changed and I wonder how you kind of fit
the pieces of that puzzle together well
that I i think there's no no simple
answer I well I recently was was
thinking about an analogy in the
wildlife preservation you know look how
people talk today about wildlife the zoo
is kind of like I mean still has a role
it's much more to preserve wildlife in
the Serengeti to keep the ways you know
of transfer open I think we will have
that for cultural heritage as well we
will definitely have this idea of you
know cultural heritage in the spirit of
the place and the spirit of the place is
the one which the various stakeholders
an associate
with it take the Berlin Wall the East
German see it differently from the West
Germans and still you know it's a it's
it's the get ahead of wonderful the
Getty conservation should have ten years
ago the values project a wonderful
project about how to identify all these
values associated with the place and I'm
sure the Potala Palace is exactly would
be a wonderful case study I don't know
how you know we will really preserve
cultural heritage it's not possible to
preserve it forever anyhow it will
change and we have to accept it ever
change we can make it as a management of
change and try to let it live as long as
possible and also we have to make sure
that our perceptions change I mean
nobody wants to return to the 18th
century and cut the people's head in the
French Revolution anymore so or let's
say I don't know even the English word
for it there was a tradition of dwell
you know in Europe when when you know
over dispute the women the men were they
shooting each other I don't know it's
just english word duels here well that
is kind of an intangible cultural
heritage which we don't want to rewrite
you don't want to get this back so we
have to live with changes in perception
and and in values and after it actually
we have to embrace the change because is
no way to say it should be like this
forever because it will not work anyhow
digital console preservation
putting paintings and objects into
digital form now thank you lynn that's
that's wonderful opportunity because I
exactly eliminated all this part from
because I thought it would be then way
too long this is like the third big
field the the preservation of digital
heritage of Dhara thank you enough of
authenticity the problem of obsolescence
of migration of media of emulations of
media we have cases that you know whole
year's records of documents were lost
because they were saved on a DD and the
papers was thrown away I mean yeah we
lose and we also might be some you know
experts say we might be in front of a
big black hole in digital preservation
because we have everything now in apps
you know we don't have really i mean if
you lose the program's you know we don't
really unsure if you can read what we
have saved me personally I have lost
hundreds of photos whenever I change a
cell phone I lose I mean I'm a very bad
example for digital preservation I lose
a lot of my contacts and my secret
numbers for my credit cards and my
photos and everything and I think that
happens not only to me and I I think
actually that also yes I could have
emphasized this in my presentation also
that Yale is a place where you know
cultural heritage computing and
networking has a home there is a
department of computer science where
where I can only say we are very very
privileged that we have professors who
who are interested in that we're not
just interested in like optimizing cell
phone apps and but really think about
cultural heritage we have you know two
postdocs here who work with computer
science and and I think it is a
challenge but it is also it's not
sufficient to say oh let's just digitize
you know that is it needs research it
needs investment and technology it's not
I mean there's no solution for that it
is a process just like preventive
conservation as well it's not a protocol
it's really a process
and we're painted over by the teacher
at what point does an action like that
becomes part of the material history of
that object that then becomes a fourth
preserving or how does that
that's a political action there that's
in response to a large-scale
how do you balance no privilege yeah
yeah yeah it's a very very good question
i mean the photo which i showed you I
took myself so that was obviously
painting where the water soluble paint
was not yet removed it was shown at the
documenta also 2013 it is I mean I said
before the conservation is management of
change I could also say conservation
starts with exploring the context the
conservation work nowadays is actually
getting this information know about the
Potala Palace you know who are the
stakeholders who are the users who has
an ownership and about an object like
this one and then collect all this
opinions and then find an idea or a way
to proceed with it we have had the time
I mean you know my colleagues from
conservation will definitely remember
you know when you had let's say mirror
painting in the polished church which
was over painted in 1700 and you went
back to the medieval painting and you
lost completely the over paint that
would probably not happen today anymore
so easily because people would say well
this is a the alteration is part of the
history as you were saying part of the
history of the object it is you know
it's like as nobody wants to make 25
year old man out of myself you know
because that doesn't work you know
there's a I mean whatever went through
history is part of me and it's also with
an object the yellow monastery in the
oak forest by caspa laboratories you
know you can remove the varnish yes you
can do things but but that's why
conservation became a scientific
profession over the past 30 years
because these colleagues they know how
things are made how things change over
time and they can assemble all this
information in kind of a even like like
a doctor like like a medical doctor in
kind of an animal easiest diagnosis and
treatment process and they can say I get
all this and now I make the decision I I
leave it like it is or I remove it or I
make it thinner you know and and and and
justified in their scientific codex and
and I think that's where we are with
conservation I mean 200 years ago there
was only about gluing an arm back to a
sculpture now you you start
like five years you know you make your
master here I think in the US but you in
German is like five year study so that
is about exploring the context and
finding a good solution which by the way
tomorrow might be a very bad one we have
to live with this to that you know the
approach is changing what today might be
I'm in a good decision tomorrow maybe
we'll be seen critically sorry entropy
is always increasing having preservation
is sort of right again as anybody sort
of thinking of it on that level or
anything like that I mean there's
nothing like like you know we're
programmed to die and basically we have
to die we don't die there won't be any
room for right could be more these kinds
of are also i mean it's very close to my
thinking as the chemist I I feel very
close to which was just saying but it's
very far away from the feeling and
emotion in the conservation department
most conservatives if you would say you
know I mean you have hundred objects
which are the ten you can lose tomorrow
and the 10 which you want to keep for 10
years and the 10 you want to keep for
100 quite often the answers I don't want
to lose any of that but we know we
losing we know that we have already lost
we have build lost buildings we have
lost sites if you look at the projection
how this country will look like with
global climate change how the the sea
borders will look in the index say 50 or
100 years whereas a lot of
archaeological sites I mean where people
settle then I just started from the NCP
GT a few years a few weeks ago it's a
disaster we will lose its no question we
will lose cultural heritage I would just
say I mean after 25 years I came to the
conclusion i can lose it yeah but I
really want to know why I really want to
know why I lose this and not that
just don't want to lose it like without
knowing anything I don't want to be not
prepared for a flood for an earthquake I
want to to to to to some emergency like
preparation emergency response measures
simple ones my colleague Lucas brothers
did this kind of analysis for museums in
pollen and he said well if you have to a
little bit about fire you reduce the
risk to the collection of a factor like
you know really high and you know it's
it's true we have entropy yes man but
you can make a decision a good decision
to to manage the risk and and reduce it
and make smart decisions that you at
least know what you are losing and why
you're losing it because we lose way too
much cultural heritage without even
being aware that we lose it that's a
very good question too I mean there is I
spoke a little bit about the world
heritage convention 1972 so these
materials are these sites or this now we
have also intangible world heritage
since 2005 these must have an
outstanding universal value they must
have something which is a no UV as the
you know unesco says so and to determine
that value that is actually a very
interdisciplinary undertaking you talk
to the archaeologists and to the art
historians and you know as I said before
for the berlin wall or for the the
person in Port Arthur you know in
Tasmania you you have people who are
inmates in the President and you have
the others who are like outside and you
know the on the mainland and everybody
has a different point of view and and is
the the task for the conservator to
actually collect all these various
perspectives to have the stakeholder
centered approach and actually that's
also what we see I mean over the past
years maybe 20 years ago it was you have
to consolidate you have to do it like
this and now you know after this
convention like not a convention like
Buddha convention which are
international conventions and heritage
preservation we we have this stakeholder
active you know as as you know David
Hume was saying the beauty is in the eye
of the beholder so you look at it you
have your point of view and you say what
you think about it and then there is no
really I mean right or wrong and and to
collect that and to come then to it well
justified decision I think that is the
task of the conservator so I think we
all this questions and discussion at the
reception in the Google center but
before we do that thank you very much